-We don't always have enough
time to cover everything
in the recent news,
so, here with a recap is one
of our writers, Amber Ruffin,
in a segment we call
"Amber Says What."
♪♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
-You guys,
things have been crazy!
Okay, first of all,
Beyoncé announced
her Renaissance World Tour
and I was like, "What?!"
-Whoo!
-Then tickets went on sale
and I was like, "What, what?!"
[ Laughter ]
So, I went online to buy
a ticket and I was like,
"Wha-a-a-t?!"
[ Laughter ]
These prices were so expensive!
I was like, like, "Who you think
you got, Beyoncé?!"
[ Laughter ]
What's that?
They do?
Oh, I'll take 14 tickets.
[ Laughter ]
Sold out?
Dang!
So then I heard that
the Kansas City Chiefs
and the Philadelphia Eagles
were going to the Super Bowl
and I was like, "What?"
[ Laughter ]
But then I heard
Rihanna's performing
at the halftime show
and I was like --
[ To Rihanna's "Work" ]
♪ What what what what what ♪
Yeah, baby!
The Chiefs and the Eagles
are not going to the Super Bowl.
They're opening for Rihanna!
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
Then I heard that Florida banned
AP African American studies
from their high schools
and I was like, "What?!"
These mother[bleep] said it...
[ Laughter ]
...and was like, "What?!"
Then I realized, hey!
I love Black history and this
decision kind of makes me
like a little, um,
Black history criminal, right?
I was like, "Wha-a-a-t?!"
I'm going to sneak children
Black history on the low.
[ Laughter ]
I'm a little Black history
Underground Railroad.
[ Laughter ]
Psst! Hey, kid, c'mere.
You want some Black history?
[ Laughter and applause ]
Madam C.J. Walker was the first
Black woman millionaire.
Now, scram,
and tell all your friends!
[ Laughter and applause ]
Then I thought, "Well, at least
Florida can't get any worse."
But then I saw that the mayor
of Miami unveiled
a new Black History Month
police car and I was like,
"What?!"
[ Laughter ]
Psst! Hey, kid.
You want some more
Black history?
Sure you do.
Now, you're hooked.
[ Laughter ]
The origins of modern day
policing can be traced back
to something called
the Slave Patrol.
Now, scram,
and tell all your friends!
[ Laughter ]
So, then I saw there was a new
dating reality show about MILFs,
called "MILF Manor,"
[ Laughter ]
and I was like, "What?!"
Is this a joke?
I know I've heard this
somewhere before.
Like didn't one of our writers,
John Lutz,
have something to do with it?
And then I remembered.
-Welcome to the MILF finals.
-Alright, Deborah!
-Oh, you suck, Deborah.
-This show is the worst.
Didn't one of those MILFs die
during production?
-She had too much champagne
and a monkey knocked her
into some quicksand.
It could've happened anywhere.
I was like, , "Wha-a-a-t?!"
[ Laughter and applause ]
"30 Rock" predicted the future.
[ Laughter ]
Also, Lutz's name
on the show was Lutz.
This man was born
with a name so funny
that some of the best comedy
writers could not beat it.
[ Laughter ]
So then I read that Connecticut
might exonerate women
who were executed
for being witches in the 1600s
and I was like, "What?!"
[ Laughter ]
You're exonerating them now?
It's 400 years too late.
[ Laughter ]
If this is how you do people
convicted of being witches,
I'd hate to see how you do
people convicted
of possession of marijuana.
What's that?
They're still in jail? Hm.
[ Laughter ]
Psst! Hey, kid, c'mere.
You want some more
Black history?
Black people are
four times more likely
to be arrested for possession.
Now, scram,
and tell all your friends!
[ Laughter ]
Okay, so then something
crazy happened.
You know that guy,
George Santos,
the congressman who got caught
telling a million lies?
Well, I read that his campaign
spent more than $26,000
at an Italian restaurant
and I was like, "What?!"
[ Laughter ]
Everything this man does
is hilarious!
[ Laughter ]
$26,000 at one restaurant?
What do they serve,
Beyoncé tickets?
[ Laughter and applause ]
Then I found out that he owed
the same restaurant
another $18,000
for an event he threw there
and I was like, "What?!"
What happens
if he doesn't pay it?
Does he get his kneecaps broken
by...
[ Laughter ]
This man lied
about school, work,
said he was Black,
said he was Jewish,
all while having a face beat
to the gods
[ Laughter ]
and eating thousands
of dollars of takeout.
Sir, you are very bad and it
will never stop bringing me joy.
[ Laughter ]
Then it was Groundhog Day!
And I read
that Punxsutawney Phil
predicted six more weeks
of winter
and I was like, "What?!"
This rat don't know the weather!
[ Laughter ]
Who does this groundhog
think he is?
Bitch, you live in a hole!
[ Laughter ]
Don't nobody wanna hear
your forecast.
You don't know [bleep]!
-Amber, are you just mad that he
said six more weeks of winter?
-[ Faux crying ]
Yes. I'm so cold.
It's no degrees outside.
We don't have any degrees.
[ Laughter ]
Then people were like,
"Did you hear Tom Brady
retired again?"
And I was like, "What?!"
That is crazy
because he is very football.
Like it's a whole thing.
Pigskin, touchdowns,
tackling field goals,
touchdowns, touch-ups --
he's got it all.
[ Laughter ]
-Amber, do you not know
who Tom Brady is?
-No, I do not.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh. He played in the NFL
for 23 seasons.
He's a legend.
-Oh! Is he that guy who kissed
his child on the mouth
and everybody hated it?
[ Laughter ]
-I mean, yeah, but.
-[ Laughs ]
Yuck.
[ Laughter ]
So, then I read
that Pope Francis said
that being gay is not a crime,
but it is a sin,
and I was like, "Wha-a-a-t?!"
[ Laughter ]
Bitch!
Now, you know what's legal
and illegal?
Where were you
during "Spotlight"?
[ Laughter ]
Pope, please.
Psst!
Hey, kid, c'mere.
[ Laughter ]
You want some Black history?
The first Black pope was
George Santos?!
[ Laughter and applause ]
Man, George Santos got into my
Black history jacket!
This has been "Amber Says What."
♪♪
[ Cheering and applause ]